.
>> DISTURBING ALLEGATIONS.
THANK YOU.
>>> THIS MORNING, THE FOCUS OF
REPUBLICAN EFFORTS TO CHANGE
STATE VOTING LAWS HAS SHIFTED TO
TEXAS.
THE STATE SENATE THERE PASSED A
BILL YESTERDAY TO LIMIT EARLY
VOTING HOURS, MAKE DRIVE-THROUGH
VOTING ILLEGAL, AND RESTRICT
VOTING BY MAIL.
DEMOCRATS IN THE COUNTRY'S
SECOND-LARGEST STATE CLAIM IT'S
INTENDED TO KEEP THEIR
SUPPORTERS AWAY FROM THE POLLS.
SENIOR WHITE HOUSE AND POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT ED O'KEEFE
REPORTS.
>> Reporter: THE TEXAS BILL IS
STILL UP FOR CONSIDERATION IN
THE STATE HOUSE, BUT DEMOCRATS
SAY IT TARGETS SOME OF THE LONE
STAR STATE'S MOST DEMOCRATIC
AREAS LIKE HARRIS COUNTY.
ENCOMPASSING HOUSTON WHERE MORE
THAN 100,000 CAST DRIVE-THROUGH
BALLOTS LAST YEAR DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
CRITICS ALSO SAY IT WOULD MAKE
IT HARDER FOR MINORITY VOTERS TO
CAST BALLOTS.
>> IT IS PART OF THIS PATTERN
THAT WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY OF BILLS THAT WOULD MAKE
IT HARDER TO VOTE AND SUPPRESS
THE VOTE.
>> Reporter: ABOUT 55 MORE
RESTRICTIVE VOTING PROPOSALS ARE
UP FOR SERIOUS CONSIDERATION IN
24 STATES.
FIVE HAVE BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW,
INCLUDING THE NEW LAW IN GEORGIA
PASSED LAST WEEK.
WHILE SOME STATES EXPANDED
VOTING OPTIONS DUE TO COVID, CBS
NEWS ELECTION LAW EXPERT DAVID
BECKER SAID PROPOSALS LIKE THE
ONE THIS TEXAS GO FAR BEYOND
RETURNING TO PRE-PANDEMIC
LEVELS.
>> THE PROVISIONS IN THE TEXAS
LAW ARE ACTUALLY MAKING TEXAS
EVEN WORSE THAN THEY WERE BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC.
IT IS MAKING IT HARDER FOR
PEOPLE TO VOTE BY MAIL.
ONE OF THE MOST RESTRICTED
STATES IF NOT THE MOST
RESTRICTED STATES FOR MAIL
VOTING IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: CORPORATE
OPPOSITION TO THE REPUBLICAN
PROPOSALS IS GROWING.
AMERICAN AIRLINES, A MAJOR TEXAS
EMPLOYER, SAYS IT STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE TEXAS BILL BECAUSE
IT WILL LIMIT VOTING ACCESS.
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS
HE SUPPORTS CALLS FROM SOME
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL PLAYERS TO
MOVE THIS SUMMER'S ALL-STAR GAME
OUT OF ATLANTA BECAUSE OF
GEORGIA'S NEW VOTING LAW.
>> THIS IS JIM CROW ON STEROIDS
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN GEORGIA
AND 40 OTHER STATES.
>> Reporter: GEORGIA REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP STRUCK BACK.
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE ARE
STANDING UP AND REALIZING THE
GAMES THAT ARE BEING PLAYED
HERE, AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
FIGHTING BACK WITH US.
>> Reporter: THE GEORGIA LAW
INCLUDES NEW RESTRICTIONS ON
VOTING BY MAIL, LIMITS WHERE
BALLOT DROP BOXES CAN BE PLACED,
AND WHEN THEY CAN BE ACCESSED,
AND GIVES THE STATE LEGISLATURE
GREATER CONTROL OVER HOUR
ELECTIONS ARE RUN.
RELIGIOUS LEADERS ARE ALSO
CALLING FOR A NATIONAL BOYCOTT
BEGINNING NEXT WEDNESDAY OF
COCA-COLA, DELTA, AND HOME
DEPOT, THREE OF ATLANTA'S
LARGEST EMPLOYERS.
COCA-COLA AND DELTA HAVE ISSUED
STATEMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
GEORGIA'S NEW VOTING LAW, BUT
THESE RELIGIOUS LEADERS SAY THE
COMPANIES SHOULD BE DOING MORE
AND SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THESE
VOTING RIGHTS LAWS THAT ARE UP
FOR CONSIDERATION IN OTHER
SATES.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN LEARNING
MORE, WE POSTED A RUNDOWN OF
SOME OF THE MORE INTERESTING
BILLS AT CBSNEWS.CO